All right. Kobi Mahat
Thank you so much for joining
on 20 Minute Leaders.
I’m really happy to be here
Okay, this is so great.
You know, I actually grew up
watching you on TV.
I grew up in Tel-Aviv
watching the children’s channel
and HaShminiya and HaPijamot and…
and all the different shows
that you got to be a part of.
And we actually even --
I've actually got to study
under your command
in a program where you taught us
how to act in front
of the camera.
So, it’s nice to close this loop
after all these years.
I actually taught you,
I think, how to host, not to act.
And there’s a big difference
if you can remember
from acting and hosting.
It’s completely
different profession.
So, it sounds like I already
failed my first test
after all these years.
No scores here.
No scores here. That’s amazing.
So, Kobi, a tank commander
in the army, going out to study
psychology and organizational
behavior in your masters,
and all of a sudden,
you find yourself
as one of the biggest stars
in Israel on a children’s show.
You’re practically an idol
for every kid
growing up in Israel.
I have to understand how this
whole sequence came about.
Well, it was virtually a mistake.
It wasn’t meant to be.
I was going to be --
my root since I was,
I think, 15 was a --
I wanted to be a psychologist
ever since my mother took me
to the book fair and bought me
“The Origins of Dreams”
of Sigmund Freud.
I don’t know if that’s the name
of the book anyways.
Those two books sort paved the way
for me to be a psychologist.
That’s what I thought
I wanted to be.
That’s what I started studying
after I was done with the army.
I think three months after
I was done with the army,
I already joined
the Tel-Aviv University
and started studying.
And what happened is
between the first and the second
degree, a friend of mine just
thought that we had
the same sense of humor.
That was very nice of him to think
we had a sense of humor
to begin with.
Anyways, we wrote something
very naïve and he sent it
to all kinds of broadcasters.
One of them,
a very famous  one in Israel,
a major broadcaster
in Israel, Keshet,
decided that it was pretty good.
They were not going to produce it,
but they’re looking
for new writers for a TV show.
And we became writers
- right in the beginning...
- [unclear] off in writing.
in a primetime TV.
And ever since,
I just started writing.
Until today,
I’m writing for a lot of adults
and kids' shows.
And went to the children’s channel
just to write and they told me
that I should host.
I didn’t know I was able to host.
- Wow! Okay. So, you’re writing –
- And I was
willing to jump to the really
deep end of the water.
And how quick
was this transition?
So, you go there to write.
And all of a sudden,
you find yourself a host.
How quickly does it go
from 0 to 60, and --
- It was pretty quick.
- you're an icon?
It was pretty quick.
It was 2000.
And in 2000, there was only one
children’s channel in Israel.
So, if you were one of the hosts,
you were a mega hit with the kids
and their parents, immediately.
And in 2000, it was pretty quick
becoming a huge success
from 0 to 100 in...
- Insane.
- no time.
Insane.
So, Kobi, try to summarize
this whole experience for me.
You go on daily on this children’s
channel and you are an icon.
And you are a role model.
How old are you at that point
when you're a --?
I was 27. I was pretty old for
a TV -- children’s TV presenter.
I was 27.
I always had sort of a baby face.
So, nobody really knew,
but I was pretty old. 27, it’s --
But Kobi, that’s a lot
of responsibility.
Like, you’re taking on this
innate responsibility.
You’re not just a host.
You’re a role model
for kids growing up.
In everything you do----
when you walk down the street
and things you see on TV,
on and off camera,
do you feel that responsibility?
Or is it like --?
You know what?
I think everybody was
over-exaggerating
the role model thing.
I think the guidelines I had,
and I always told other hosts
that came after me
was just pure common sense.
If I was standing in the street
and I wanted to cross the road,
I would go and wait
for the green light.
Maybe as an adult,
sometimes, I could --
I could --
you could cut some corners
and cross on the red light.
But I took it upon myself
to understand that some kids
and their parents maybe standing
and watching me, and --
but that was about it.
You shouldn’t exaggerate.
I was over 20, 27.
I could drink alcohol in parties.
It’s okay.
I wasn’t alarmed if a paparazzi
caught me drinking.
It’s okay. I’m old enough.
So, everything within limits.
Just pure common sense.
And talk to me about this,
about writing.
So, you transitioned
from being a host there.
You’re writing for these --
for a lot of different shows.
You appear in a lot of these
shows as an actor yourself.
What is it about this writing
that really caught your attention
because, again, you were
going to be a psychologist?
You were going
for organizational behavior.
How do you --?
Where does this writing
aspect come from?
Well, I think it’s a bug.
It’s a bug in the system.
And it’s a bug that --
it’s some sort of a tick
that when it hits you
and if it’s right for you,
it’s really hard.
It’s a pandemic.
A lot of people
want to be famous,
but I never wanted to be famous.
Still, my main attraction
to this area of --
to this career is not being famous.
So, what I really like is the --
you need to have
any intermediate
between you and the audience.
It was very forward.
You could have touched them.
Yeah.
It was very, very immediate.
And I never knew
I wanted to do it.
Sometimes, you’re very talented
in something
you have not tried yet.
Maybe you’re a great cook
or a great knitter.
I don’t know
if you tried knitting.
- Have you tried it?
- Never in my life.
Maybe you’re very talented
- in knitting.
- Maybe.
And maybe someday,
someone who’s
a great knitter will find
this talent in you
and you’ll become a knitter.
Oh, I should change my name.
It’s not my name here.
Okay. It’s Kobi Mahat
or [gibberish].
On the Zoom, it was Nissim
or something. Wait.
Yeah.
But Kobi, I want to go
to this moment
where you’re writing a show
or your writing a movie,
and you work in it for years.
And you cast,
and you get funding, and –
I never work on
anything for years. Never.
Really?
Yes.
In the last six years,
I’ve written
and directed six movies.
Six movies in six years.
And I think that’s
an Israeli record.
And I’m all for
immediate satisfactions.
I’m envious of people
that can wait and dream
and sit on their ideas
for so long.
I’m very, very fast.
When I’m getting
into a new production,
I’m going in there
like a bulldozer.
Sometimes, you have to
attract sponsors --
Yeah.
-- to invest in the movie.
I’m not shy of begging people,
of making presentation
of anything.
But I think --
and my record speaks for itself.
That’s unbelievable.
Six movies in --
Just the Avatar, I think,
took 30 years to produce.
It’s a great movie.
I’m not even in --
It’s not the same level.
- I'm not trying to say --
- No, no, no, of course, but --
But you know, Israel is
a very small country.
And we have only,
I don’t know,
about 9 million people.
- That's the --
- Yeah.
The population, it's very small.
So, the budgets for the movies
are really small.
But as an Israeli,
and everybody who has done
anything in Israel,
whether it’s being
a tank commander
in the Israeli army
or making a movie,
you know that --
we know how to make a dollar
and a half out of a dollar.
Definitely. Definitely.
And I always say also,
especially here in my community,
in Silicon Valley and Stanford,
when they ask me,
“Well, what is about Israeli
that’s like the number one thing,”
I mainly say,
"We get [expletive] done."
That's what it's about
- at the end.
- That's true.
That's true.
It is true. But Kobi -- so still,
you work on a movie for a year
and it hits the theaters.
It’s the premier.
You’re sitting down
with your friends,
your family,
the sponsors and the audience,
and this movie starts.
Is there a fear in you of
how people will react to it?
How are people going to
react to your masterpiece?
There’s excitement.
And the excitement
stems also from --
a little bit from fear --
Yeah.
because in some sense,
I considered myself --
I consider myself an artist.
And artists, when you put your
art to the audience,
it’s very different sometimes
the way they think.
Sometimes, when I plan a joke --
All of my movies are funny.
And when I plan
a joke and I
think I know where the audience
is going to laugh,
and they’re not laughing,
it’s like a punch in the stomach.
On the other hand,
sometimes, they laugh
when they weren’t meant to laugh.
Is it okay?
Yes, it’s okay.
I was not embarrassed yet.
Hopefully, it’s not
going to happen.
Amazing. Amazing.
Kobi, that fear though, is that --
I mean, I know a lot of people --
I’m a coder.
I’m a software engineer
by profession and an investor.
And when I go and I look at deals,
or I look at codes that I write
and I pass it onto others,
I don’t really care
if they criticize it,
if they say it’s awful.
Like, I have to redo it.
It’s objective.
It’s science. It’s math.
But when you put an art
into something,
you put heart there,
I’m sure it’s really hard
to make that distinction.
And maybe you
haven’t gotten burned,
but is this something,
a phenomena in the industry
that people are fearful of?
Or is this --?
- Or do you exemplify
- Everybody is --
it's common?
I’m fearful --
First of all, there are a couple of
audiences that watches your film.
The first one
is the actual audience that buy
tickets and go to the theater.
And they’re my main focus.
I want as many as I can
to come to the theaters
and enjoy the movie.
That’s my main focus.
The other kind of audience
is the critics.
Right.
I really want the critics
to like my movie.
But their opinion
is only their opinion.
So, although it has
some distribution,
maybe bigger than --
and it was one --
it hurts when someone writes
something bad on your movie.
It happened to me.
The third audience is my
sponsors and my investors.
I really want them to think
it’s a good movie.
So, I’m mainly focused
on the bigger audience,
the real people and my investors.
The others, I can live
without their love.
How do you work?
I want to know your station.
Do you have a computer?
And when you write a script
or a movie, do you just sit down
and start writing
on a Word document?
Do you write it by hand
on a big wall?
How does it work?
Oh, these days I’m actually
thinking about a new idea.
I was just --
I’m just done with the filming
of my new movie
and it’s now
in the process of editing.
Okay.
So, I’m actually thinking
about the new idea.
I don’t know
if it’s going to be a movie
or a series, or whatever.
But I'm like --
It’s a stew inside my head.
I’m thinking about it a lot.
And for the last four days,
I think I have a story
in my head.
And I’m thinking about
tomorrow star --
sitting in front of my PC,
a stationary, computer,
not a laptop,
not an iPad, not in a restaurant
or a coffee shop.
In my house, in my small room,
the one I’m sitting here
right now,
and I just started writing drafts.
Is it just like word vomit?
Do you just write
as much as you can,
and then sleep on it and revise?
Or do you really think
through every --?
No, I think through.
I think it’s true
and nevertheless,
some of it is vomit.
Some of it is going
to be erased in a day,
and a new thing
is going to come up.
It’s a process of,
I don’t know,
two weeks to write
just the synopsis,
that three good pages of
- Wow!
- the story with all the outlines
and the main
characters and everything.
Do you miss going back
in front of the camera
and being the star?
I’m still in front of the camera.
Actually, until the COVID9
pandemic, I had a daily show
six days a week
with Yael Bar Zohar.
It was called the Daily Report.
Yeah.
Six days a week.
So, I’m pretty much
every day on TV.
And it’s a major
broadcaster in --
It’s Reshet.
And I’ve just --
Since the COVID-19
pandemic happened,
we were laid off.
But I was just given
the very pleasant news
today that we’re coming
back next week.
So, I’m still on TV.
- It’s a really –
- But it’s a very --
But it’s very different,
in this kind of TV than what you
write because it’s
two different worlds.
One you’re a host.
The report with Yael Bar Zohar,
it’s a great show.
But you’re not acting.
You’re hosting.
And then, you’re a fiction writer
for movies and series
where it’s completely made up,
stories that you’re
creating, right?
Yeah, but it’s no different than
you being a great cook
and being a computer engineer.
Right.
I mean, we all have --
some of the things
I don’t like on the little screen
or the big screen
is that it tries --
people are always trying to make
a two-dimension picture of you.
I’m a three-dimension person and –
- I love it! I love it.
- I have a lot of interests.
So, I can write and I can host,
and I can do a couple of --
I actually can cook.
I’m a really good
[flutter], I think.
- So, I have a lot of interests
- I love it.
and one of them gives me
the relief from the other.
I mean, if I only
did writing or directing,
I would go crazy.
Also, if I was only a host,
I’d probably be
in a sanctuary right now.
This passion that you have of
trying inter-disciplinary things
and doing all to your passions
shines through the screen.
But I want one piece of advice
that you would give to
any young person,
not necessary much of --
neural coder, actor,
musician, whatever,
any person who wants to go
after their dream,
is a little bit hesitant.
And from what I learned, and I
didn’t know all this about you,
is about how passionate
you are about going through things
that you enjoy
and that you really love
without being scared of
what others will say.
Or whether it fits this scenario
box people are trying
to put you on.
Yeah. I think my main advice --
I give advice to a lot
of young people.
A lot of people approached me
and ask for my advice,
want to send me scripts
they’ve written from
the ages of 14 until the --
I don’t know, the oldest --
I’ve got a script from was
I think, 65.
Wow!
And I never turned down nobody.
I read.
I read and I give them advice.
- I'm not always --
- Wow!
I cannot always help,
and I can’t always
take their idea and --
but I give them advice
and maybe some pinpoints
- how to make it better.
- Wow!
Sometimes, it’s not good enough
and I tell the truth, softly.
But I’m telling the truth always.
My main advice for those
people is to be --
stay very, very curious.
When you’re curious as I am,
you explore.
And when you explore,
you discover a lot of things.
The way I’ve become a director
was through me being the host
and the writer.
I was watching the people
that I work with.
I wanted to know
what kind of camera they use.
Why are they using these kind of
dolly and not the other one?
How can you make this effective
than the other, and so on?
And I taught myself a little bit
of editing, and a little bit of
content editing,
and a lot of things that are not
necessarily exactly directing,
but I’ve broadened my horizons.
And when I’ve done that,
I think I’ve become a better
host and a better director.
So being curious is
- I love it.
- very, very important.
I love it. So, Kobi,
three words that describe you.
One of them is curious.
I’m going to use that already.
I just wanted to  say curious,
curious and curious
because I think --
a lot of people think
being smart --
okay, I’ll give you another
one that I’m very good at.
I’m very organized.
Okay.
And one of the psychologists
I worked with,
I had a very interesting show
on television
with Professor Amos [unclear].
He taught me that --
He always says that the person
who succeed in life
is the one who’s organized
over the one who’s smart.
And I mean,
it’s very good to be both.
But if you had to choose one,
being organized is very,
very important.
And I’m very --
If you can see my table here,
it’s very organized.
And I think because I do
all sorts of things
and there's a lot of
scrambled eggs inside my head,
I need some
organization to the system.
And being organized
is a very important thing.
Being curious is very important.
And I think the third, which
I’m not sure I’m always good at
but is very important
to stay humble
And I say that because,
of course, as a person on TV,
I also made the same --
of hubris.
Everybody does that
on television.
We tend to think that the sun
shines from our butts.
It’s never true.
And times like this,
like COVID-19.
and what it made to our industry,
made a lot of people
very, very humble.
And being humble
in the first place
gives you a soft
cushion to land on.
I love it. Kobi, I can’t believe
20 minutes are up.
It was so inspiring.
Toda raba for all the information
and for giving me
so much enjoyment
growing up, really.
Thank you very much.
This is actually a footage
from my new film.
- It’s called “Full Speed."
- Oh!
Full Speed.
When is it --?
Is it going to be in theaters?
How do we even watch it
after COVID-19?
Oh, of course. It’s going to be --
Well, the premier is supposed
to be on August, 1st of August.
Hopefully, if everything
is going to be okay
with the COVID-19 thing --
actually, we’re depending
on the Hollywood industry,
to release their films that will
ignite the Israeli film industry.
- Yeah.
- So, I’m going to be ready.
And it’s a great movie
about women strength.
It’s really good.
I can’t wait. Kobi –
Written by a man.
Thank you very much, Michael.
Toda raba.
- Yeah.
- All right.
Bye-bye.